vous avez l'intention d'organiser des
voyages de groupe pour que les femmes
françaises puissent aller se faire
avorter à l'étranger on est un peu loin
du du concept vous confondez avec ivg ou
c d e régis les enterrements de vie de
garçon et moins dans le helmand la plus
de bébés ils croient plus dans le et on
va faire des bébés
je vais être clair avec vous pour 400
euros
vous allez vous la coller comme des
malades à budapest
qu'est-ce qui fait kiffer les gars
poursuivre par des chiens
[Musique]
la seule chose qu'on vous demande c'est
d'avoir un passeport en cours de
validité talent et c'est tout bon
combien de ventes aujourd'hui les gars
12 12 super tu as fait combien toile 3 3
vous allez élire et tu casses cesse
comme des clochards de chez castel je me
fais chier moi je n'en peux plus corps
on en est où 10 ans plus tard c'est koi
no job c'est de la merde attentant me
dire on va monter une boîte qui organise
des internautes eu deux garçons en
hongrie oui parce qu'on n'est pas
rentrée chez castel est exact où touche
pas
van den putte elle a été pendant deux
ans un genre homo sapiens
j'espère c'est qu'à la police au plus
tard c'est la police mais du skull
[Musique]